Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Meinst du, bei dem großen europäischen Projekt der Völkerverständigung ist dieses
Mal für uns was zu gewinnen?
Ich glaube, bei der Europawahl haben wir alle schon verloren.
Vielen Dank, everyone. Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 495 haben wir heute.
Und ja, Fußball.
Damit man was hat, worum man sich beschäftigen und ablenken kann,
damit man nicht so viel über die Europawahl nachdenken muss.
Also ich bin zufrieden mit dem Trikot ohne Schwarz, Rot und Gold.
Das steht unserem internationalen Team sehr gut.
Das stimmt. Scheint ja auch zu helfen.
Das erste Spiel haben sie ja mit dem hässlichen Trikot auch ganz gut hingekriegt.
Heimtrikot Ich finde ja ein weißes Trikot eigentlich auch ganz okay Nee.
Ein weißes Trikot sieht einfach scheiße aus Sieht scheiße aus.
Was hast du gegen weiß?
Es sieht scheiße aus, hab ich doch schon gesagt Also es sieht einfach nicht
aus Es sieht einfach nicht aus Hast du ja auch gesehen Guck mal,
gestern Spiele gegen Ungarn Hast du ja gesehen, weiß sieht nicht aus Es sieht einfach nicht aus.
Na gut, das ist so Stilschlag. Aber das scheint ja eh so ein Problem zu sein,
dass wir uns bei den Farben gerade nicht so einig werden.
Ich fand vor allem die Farben bei der Europawahl halt irgendwie auch schlecht gewählt.
Und da werden wir uns nicht einig oder was?
Wir beide werden uns da wahrscheinlich schon einig, aber so Deutschland an sich.
Deutschland hat ein Farbproblem.
Ja genau, definitiv. Da gibt es eine, wie heißt das so schön,
man hat eine Farbenblindheit.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Deutschland eine Farbenblindheit hat.
Nee, meinst du nicht?
Was wäre die Komplementärfarbe zu blau? Gelb, ne? Und die Komplementärfarbe zu braun? Braun.
Okay, wir kriegen da keine richtige Wissenschaft draus gemacht.
Aber ist auch nicht alles schlecht, weil es wurde ja in manchen Ländern dann
auch, wurden ja auch andere Trends eingeleitet.
Also hat zum Beispiel Herr Orban in Ungarn durchaus Plätze eingebüßt mit seiner Fetisch.
Also das ist halt dann immer so mit diesen Sinuswellen. Aber es lässt sich nicht
wegdiskutieren, dass wir gerade so eine Art, ja ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das nennen soll.
Irgendwo gab es so einen Artikel über irgendwelche Schnuller-Nazis mit,
ja wir waren ja schon rechts, bevor es cool war und ich habe so ein bisschen die Befürchtung.
Wen meinst du irgendwie?
Werteunion?
Können wir das einspielen? Hans-Georg Maaßen bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung der Werteunion.
Siegmund Freud spricht mit.
Meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren, und jetzt komme uns, zur Partei, die Werteunion. Union.
Sehr, sehr schön. Aber da kann man dem Mann keinen Vorwurf machen,
das wäre mir auch passiert. Das wäre mir auch passiert.
Das Schönste an diesem Video ist, das ist ja so ein kurzer Videoclip,
wie dann so eine Security-Gestalt, die dann so im Hintergrund ist.
Was hat er gesagt?
Also, ja.
Da sollte man schon mal die Nase rümpfen.
Ne, das wäre mir auch passiert. Also da kann man echt keinen Vorwurf machen. Ja gut, also.
Es ist ein merkwürdiges Ding und das halt gerade bei Jugendlichen,
dass jetzt sozusagen so hip geworden ist, das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Ja, das ist wirklich nicht klar, aber also,
Man würde ja hoffen, wenn man wenigstens mal die Nachrichten vergleicht,
dann gibt es halt, also seit langer Zeit setzt sie sich damit auseinander,
dass die AfD als einzige Partei auf TikTok Gas gibt.
Und ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die alten Rentnerfaschisten auf TikTok abgehangen
haben. Ja, insofern, wenn, das könnte schon sein, dass das da auch eine Rolle spielt.
Ja, müsste man mal noch ausarbeiten. Ich meine, zu anderen Zeitpunkten haben
diese zarten Seelen irgendwie in großen Mengen die FDP gewählt.
Also, man muss da irgendwie vielleicht auch die Kinder schützen,
ist ja ohnehin ein Thema.
Kinderschutz jetzt mal richtig.
Kinderschutz jetzt mal, Kinderschutz ernst genommen.
Kinderschutz jetzt erst recht.
Ja, aber man kann das nicht wegdiskutieren. Ich habe so Interviews gesehen,
wo Jugendliche befragt wurden, warum sie denn jetzt irgendwie AfD gewählt haben
und die ganzen Triggerpoints, das waren halt alles diese Right-Wing-Talking-Points,
die halt relativ wenig Wahrheit in sich tragen,
aber die halt dann einfach reingehämmert werden. Ja, so.
Die Flüchtlinge nehmen uns irgendwie das, nehmen uns alles weg und wir können
uns das ja nicht leisten und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Also das, was Rechte immer sagen und das ist ein bisschen traurig,
das so zu sehen, dass das so aufgenommen wird.
Tja.
Insgesamt scheint ja sowieso, also wenn man sich die politische Debatte,
wenn man sich anschaut, was so politisch passiert, ist es auf jeden Fall,
kann man glaube ich erkennen,
dass wir uns nicht notwendigerweise mit den Problemen befassen,
die wir haben, also die wir wirklich haben.
Und bei denen, die wir haben, nicht notwendigerweise mit Lösungen dafür.
Also so als wenn man mal sagen würde, okay, wir haben ein Problem mit dieser
ganzen Klimageschichte.
Dann könnte man sagen, also wenn man das annimmt, was glaube ich nur noch die
absoluten TikTok-Ultras nicht mehr glauben,
Dann könnte man auf jeden Fall sagen, dass wir uns damit nicht korrekt auseinandersetzen.
Man könnte sagen, dass wir andere Dinge, wo man sogar überlegen könnte,
ob es überhaupt ein Problem ist,
dass wir die in der Diskussion überbetonen und man könnte dann sogar noch weiterfragen,
ob man für die denn wenigstens an der Lösung diskutieren würde und man könnte
da sogar zu dem Ergebnis kommen, dass wir das auch nicht tun.
Also es ist schon sehr, sehr schräg, die politischen Diskurse und Auseinandersetzungen gerade.
Ja, die Piraten hat es dann auch erwischt. Also Patrick Breyer hatte ja eh angekündigt,
dass er rausgeht aus dem Europaparlament.
Das heißt, angekündigt stand nicht zur Wahl.
Aber jetzt ist auch dieser eine Sitz verloren gegangen.
Hat sich alles so auf andere Splitterparteien verteilt. Ja.
Piraten einfach mal kompetente Leute in in diesem Parlament.
Das darf man nicht vergessen. Ich habe aber jetzt mal auch das Buch von Nico
Semsrott zu seiner Zeit im Europaparlament durchgelesen.
Das ist schon auch sehr ernüchternd. Da hätte man, muss man wirklich sagen,
da hätte man sich gewünscht, dass jetzt, also was mich eigentlich am meisten
schockiert hat, ist mit wie wenig Humor der aus der Nummer rausgekommen ist.
Also weißt du, Also das ist wirklich schockierend, wenn du denkst,
du hast fünf Jahre das und du bist Kabarettist oder Satiriker oder wie auch
immer man das nennen darf und du
kommst irgendwie mit jetzt nicht wirklich nennenswerten Pointen da raus.
Da muss das schon wirklich, wirklich schlimm sein.
Also das ist schon wirklich, wirklich hart.
It's not for everybody.
Okay, also wurde glaube ich lange genug diskutiert. Wir müssen jetzt hier keine Wahlanalyse machen.
Es ist relativ klar, wir haben ja auch in unserer letzten Sendung uns schon
mit Arne Semsrott unterhalten über Strategien nach der Machtübernahme.
Das ist wirklich keine gute Entwicklung und sicherlich keine demokratische und
wir widmen uns jetzt unseren anderen Themen.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt weiter und tun, als wäre nichts geschehen.
Und erweitern den Radius unserer Grundstückssuche nochmal auf EmoScout.
Ja, nee, kann auch außerhalb von Europa.
Umkreis 10.000 Kilometer.
Ob es da so sehr viel besser ist, da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Aber vielleicht wäre so ein AfD-Verbot doch keine schlechte Idee gewesen.
Ja, ist ja, naja, ist ja jetzt wieder, es wird wieder stärker,
es gibt da jetzt wieder einen Aufruf.
Ich möchte sowieso sagen, dass wir in unseren Themen zur AfD im Prinzip immer
ein bisschen sehr am Zahn der Zeit waren oder was.
Mit der Forderung nach einem AfD-Verbot hat sich Stefan Pelzer hier klar als
Pionier in Stellung gebracht.
Mit Jean Peters von Korrektiv haben wir darüber gesprochen.
Wir haben Arne hier gehabt mit, okay, wenn die Scheiße dann im Ventilator ist, wie geht man damit um?
Da haben wir uns jetzt viel mit befasst.
Insofern beschäftigen wir uns jetzt mal mit anderen Sachen.
Beschäftigen wir uns jetzt. Verlinken wir die Forderungen zum AfD-Verbot,
ohne sie jetzt hier nochmal zu wiederholen. Die Argumente dürften bekannt sein.
Ich habe irgendwie letztens auf LinkedIn dazu mal gepostet.
Da kommen dann auch teilweise noch Leute, die nach den Argumenten fragen.
Das ist dann immer, also wenn ich dann auch denke, ja nee, du,
pass auf, also wenn du das heute nicht begriffen hast, wirst du das jetzt nicht
in der LinkedIn-Kommentarspalte verstehen.
Ich habe außerdem auch echt gerade nicht genug Buntstifte, um dir das nochmal
zu erklären. Also das ist echt so. Naja, okay.
Wir haben hier schon mehrmals darauf hingewiesen, dass man sich bitte den 31. August vormerken soll.
Und dieser 31. August wird jetzt ergänzt durch ein weiteres Datum, nämlich den 26.
Juni. Nee, 25, Entschuldigung, 25. Juni.
25.
Juni Am Abend des 25. Juni werden wir den Vorverkauf starten,
Und wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr frühzeitig die Tickets bestellt,
damit wir jetzt eine Planungssicherheit haben,
ein Budget haben für die Veranstaltung und vor allem auch, damit ihr die Sicherheit
habt, ein Ticket zu haben und gegebenenfalls eure Berlin-Reise buchen könnt.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Sache, die damit einhergeht. Der 31.
August liegt an einem Wochenende, es ist ein Samstagabend.
Das heißt, wir werden auch früh genug Schluss machen, dass ihr dann in die Peak-Bergheinschlange
euch anstellen könnt. Also garantiert werdet ihr dann am Berghain sein,
wenn die Schlange am längsten ist.
Dass ihr auch die volle Touri-Erfahrung in Berlin mitnehmen könnt.
Aber auch so, dass ihr einen Freitag und einen Samstag in der Stadt verbringen
könnt. Und Sonntag, ein Wochenende in Berlin.
Berlin, Berlin, wir fahren nach Berlin.
Dass das alles in trockenen Tüchern ist.
Ja, was dem einen sein DFB-Pokalfinale ist, dem anderen sein LMP 500.
UEFA Abschlussspiel ist glaube ich auch in Berlin.
Das Europameisterschaftsfinale.
Also ein Highlight jagt das andere.
Könnte eigentlich direkt da bleiben.
Eigentlich direkt so, dass Gute ist.
Die Hotelkosten sind deutlich niedriger.
Könnte ja beim Adlon mal fragen, ob die für die Suite irgendwie einen Rabatt
geben, wenn man die für den ganzen Monat nimmt.
Genau. Kommt alle.
Und wenn die sagen nein, dann sagt der Udo Lindenberg, zahlt doch auch sicherlich
nicht die Standardrate im Kempinski.
Das könnte er wieder auch nicht erzählen. Naja, also, dann könnt ihr Shirts
vorbestellen und wir werden diese Shirts, das Surprise-Shirt,
das Design ist noch nicht final.
Der arme Designer ist gerade so in der 84.
Diskussions- und Abnahmerunde mit Tim. Das wird sich noch ziehen,
aber wir werden dann irgendwann einen Druckauftrag erteilen und dann gibt es
Shirts. Deswegen, Shirts könnt ihr nur vorbestellen und nur bis 31.07.
Ungefähr einen Monat brauchen wir dann für die Produktion.
Das heißt, bitte auch da beachten, das wird nicht ewig gehen,
weil diese Shirts müssen produziert werden, damit ihr die bekommt.
Man kann sich das gar nicht mehr vorstellen in der heutigen Zeit,
wo alles einfach nur im Internet ist und man klickt und das kommt am nächsten Tag.
Aber dieses Shirt, da gibt es wirklich Menschen, die bedrucken die erst,
bevor ihr die kriegt und deswegen wäre es cool, wenn ihr ein Shirt haben möchtet,
dass ihr das mitbestellt.
Wir werden sicherstellen, dass ihr das auch haben wollt, wenn ihr es dann seht.
Das ist genau, jetzt können wir mal sehen, wie sehr ihr uns vertraut Wenn ich
sage, ist ein geiles Shirt und Tim sagt, ist ein geiles Shirt und der Designer in der 84.
Nachspielminute mit Tim den fünften Elfmeter vergeigt,
Dann wisst ihr Dann fällt.
Das alles auf uns zurück.
Ja, also ich glaube.
Das passt schon.
Ich glaube, das wird euch dann schon passen Ansonsten werdet ihr sicher keine
Schwierigkeiten haben, dass ihr an jemanden anders lustig werdet Genau, Shirt gibt es auch.
Das denke ich nämlich auch, genau. Im Prinzip ist das einfach eine Geldanlage,
so ein Shirt, so ein limitiertes LNP 500, ist einfach eine Investition auch in die Zukunft.
Ja, also die anderen Leute kaufen Immobilien, können drin wohnen.
Tesla-Aktien und so weiter, was sind das alles für Enttäuschungen?
Es gibt eigentlich nur zwei gute Investitionen, eine Wohnung,
weil du da kannst auch drin wohnen und danach mit Wertzuwachs verkaufen und
LNP-Shirt, weil da kannst du sogar drin sein.
Da kannst du einfach drin sein. Nein, in deiner eigenen Wohnung auch.
In deiner eigenen Wohnung, dein eigenes LFB-Shirt.
Daran erkennst du einfach den gewieften Eigentümer. Du bist einfach nur noch
Eigentümer. Du bist gar nicht mehr...
Ich würde sogar noch weitergehen. Investor eigentlich.
Kannst du auch einen Aufsichtsrat noch gründen für dein Shirt und da Leute reinberufen
und vor allem in dem Shirt kannst du deine eigenen Entscheidungen treffen.
Da rät dir keiner rein.
Das ist einfach ein Traum.
Das ist, man muss einfach ein Produkt finden, was dir das anbietet.
Das ist so geil, vielleicht behalten wir die einfach alle für uns.
Das machen wir doch eh. Ja.
So, wenn es, weil Weil wir diesen Job selber machen und so.
Es könnte sein, dass wir für die Rolli-Tickets, die es gibt,
eventuell nicht in dem initialen Launch, die schon anbieten.
Wir haben aber dann das Kontingent reserviert.
Sollte da irgendetwas, sollte das noch nicht klar sein, dann meldet euch einfach
per E-Mail bei uns. E-Mail findet ihr auf unserer Webseite.
Oder wartet noch, weil wir haben das im Saal geplant, da gibt es glaube ich
sogar einen definierten Bereich für.
Wir machen das ganz klar, ganz klassisch, Begleitpersonen und so weiter. Sorgen wir alles für.
Sollten wir das bis dahin noch nicht hinbekommen haben, bis 25.
Juni, 18 Uhr, dann seht uns nach. Selbstverständlich haben wir an euch gedacht.
All right.
Über die Chatkontrolle, wo der belgische Ratsvorsitz quasi gerne mit einem Mandat
wieder zurückgegangen wäre in den Trilog.
Also es handelte sich dabei nicht um irgendwie eine offizielle Abstimmung,
sondern um einen sogenannten Co-Rap,
wo also die Ratspräsidentschaft Belgien abfragt, ob es Mehrheiten gibt,
auf deren Basis sie weiter in den Trilog gehen kann.
Also es ist keine klassische Abstimmung, also eigentlich gar nichts,
es ist einfach nur so, wer vielleicht schon mal in dem einen oder anderen Plenum
sein Dasein fristen musste,
kennt vielleicht Stimmungsbild.
Das Stimmungsbild ist ja immer so, haben wir das jetzt zu Ende diskutiert oder
muss die Redeliste doch noch hier in die Nachspielzeit,
in die Verlängerung eigentlich.
Und genau, das war das.
Wir müssen jetzt auch bei den Fußballterminen bleiben.
Wir bleiben bei den Fußballterminen, wir ziehen das jetzt eisenhaft durch. Du wolltest es so.
Es ist Europawahl.
Ja.
Du hast ja hier mit Elfmeter versenken und so weiter angefangen. Jetzt bleib mal dabei.
Ja, ich bleib dabei. Bin ja dabei, ich geb mir ja Mühe.
Du bist ein kompletter Fan.
Ich stürme so weit vor, ich muss nur aufpassen, dass ich nicht in die Abseitsfalle gerate.
Das stimmt.
Und so, jetzt war die Überlegung, sie hatten einen neuen Vorschlag und dieser Vorschlag war,
mal wieder lustig. Also die Argumentationslinie ist natürlich weiterhin,
naja, wir greifen ja gar nicht in die Verschlüsselung ein, wenn wir auf allen
Endgeräten ein AI-basiertes Überwachungssystem einbauen, was direkt auf den
Geräten außerhalb der Verschlüsselung die Inhalte kontrolliert.
Das ist ja kein Angriff auf Verschlüsselung, Verschlüsselung, wo sind wir denn weiter?
Das haben die natürlich, also damit haben sie niemals irgendwie auch nur eine
sachverständige Person jemals blenden können.
Das andere, das, was sie jetzt machen wollten, den Taschenspielertrick,
den sie jetzt machen wollten, war so, wir zwingen auch keinen dazu.
Wir zwingen auch keinen dazu, weil du musstest quasi der Chatkontrolle zustimmen.
Also, du hast dann, was weiß ich, dein,
Messenger und dann sagt er, wir müssen jetzt hier Chatkontrolle machen. Ja.
Und dann, ne, kennst du ja vom Internet, ganz klein so.
Andere Optionen.
Andere Optionen, ja. Und dann kannst du halt auf andere Optionen gehen.
Und da steht dann, ich verzichte einfach darauf, Videos und Bilder zu versenden.
Ich gehe hier auf die Nur-Text-Variante.
So, ne. AI, also das ist eigentlich Chat-Control.
Also wir hatten dieses Thema besprochen, Pay or Okay, was ja bei den Webseiten
ja so ist, dass sie sagen, möchtest du diese Webseite kostenlos sehen? Und alle so, ja.
Und dann so, alles klar, hiermit hast du 148.000 Trackern zugestimmt,
die dich jetzt verfolgen im Internet. Internet, ungefähr so wäre es dann,
möchtest du diesen Messenger in vollem Umfang nutzen?
Ja oder nein? Und wenn nicht, dann kommt halt eine AI-Überwachung.
Dann kannst du halt auf die AI-Überwachung verzichten. Also im Prinzip eine
erzwungene Zustimmung. Was nach Datenschutzgrundverordnung, glaube ich,
schon mal ohnehin eine komplett absurde Sache ist.
Deswegen gehen Max Schrems mit Neub ja auch gegen diese Pay-or-Okay-Modelle vor.
Also ein absolut absurder Vorgang mal wieder.
Und jetzt zitterten wir, weil heute quasi durch diese Abstimmung,
dass das Mandat gewesen wäre, mit dem der Rat in den Trilog gegangen wäre.
Und jetzt ändert sich aber der Rat, weil Belgien muss jetzt gehen.
Als nächstes ist es jetzt in den Händen von Ungarn, also nicht unbedingt in besseren Händen.
Wir hatten sehr kurzfristig jetzt am Wochenende dann auch allerhand Pressemitteilungen dazu, Signal,
Meredith Whitaker hat sich wieder gemeldet, wir haben als CCC verdächtig zeitgleich,
also da muss auch nochmal einer gucken,
wie das sein kann, Verdächtig zeitgleich ein Statement veröffentlicht,
in dem Meredith auch zitiert wurde.
Threema hat sich wieder gemeldet und noch viele weitere.
Dieser Druck scheint potenziell gewirkt zu haben, denn diese Abstimmung soll
jetzt offenbar doch nicht stattfinden.
Also dieses Meinungsbild, Stimmungsbild soll nicht stattfinden und es sieht
also jetzt damit aus, damit danach aus, dass...
Ja, dass das jetzt erstmal wieder auf dem Abstellgleis ist und dann kommen die
Ungarn und greifen das wieder an. Und was von den Ungarn zu halten ist,
haben wir gestern gesehen in Stuttgart.
2-0. Aber.
Genau, also um es nochmal kurz erklärt zu haben, es geht hier um einen Move im Rat.
Der Rat der Europäischen Union ist quasi sozusagen die Gruppe aller europäischen Regierungen.
Das betrifft nicht das Parlament und das ist letzten Endes ein signifikantes,
nicht allein entscheidendes Gremium, weil es dann ja immer noch in diesen Trilog mündet.
Aber wenn der Rat sich halt dagegen stellt, dann ist das Ding halt eigentlich schon mal durch.
Und ja, es liegt jetzt in den Händen von Ungarn insofern,
als dass es sich jetzt eben abzeichnet, dass Belgien, anders als sie das vorhatten,
das in ihrer Legislaturperiode nicht mehr hinbekommen und jetzt geht der Vorsitz eben an Ungarn.
Und ehrlich gesagt, das stimmt mich insofern ganz positiv, als dass ich das
Gefühl habe, dass Herr Orban Schwierigkeiten haben wird, in dieser EU wirklich zu führen.
Also der steht da einfach, mit den Allianzen ist es schwierig gerade.
Ich habe übrigens gerade noch eine Sache vergessen, die man nicht schicken darf.
Ich sehe das hier gerade in der Pressemitteilung von Patrick Breyer.
Also keine Bilder und keine Fotos, keine Videos, ne?
Aber auch keine Links. Also,
schau mal hier, also du kannst das Ding wirklich nur noch benutzen, um irgendwas zu tippen.
Also es ist schon wirklich, da kann man dann, könnte man nochmal den absoluten
Klassiker funktional kaputt bemühen.
Ja, das ist wirklich funktional kaputt.
Funktional kaputt, die zweite.
Ja, das Das ist eine absolut irre Idee,
aber damit haben sie es fast geschafft, mehrere Staaten halt zum Wackeln zu
bringen, dass sie dachten, achso, ja okay, wenn wir niemanden zwingen,
dann ist das ja in Ordnung, optional und so.
Und ich meine, die Vorstellungen, die sich dahinter befinden,
also es hat jetzt auch, André hatte das zitiert, das war auch wieder so ein,
man kann es ja wirklich nur noch als Bonmot zusammenfassen.
Sebastian Fiedler, das ist ein SPD-Politiker und Polizist, ich glaube der ist
auch im Bund der Kriminalbeamten, der sagt in dem Kontext, es dürften gar keine Handys im Umlauf sein,
die es überhaupt ermöglichen, mit strafbarem Material umgehen zu können.
Es also zu öffnen, zu bearbeiten oder zu versenden. Und er behauptet,
das wäre technisch möglich.
Also überleg dir mal, wie absolut irrsinnig diese Forderung ist.
Also das ist da, glaube ich, da ist, also ich glaube, dass er da technisch noch
ein bisschen, also sagen wir mal, da ist seine Vorstellung von Möglichkeit der Technik voraus.
Er müsste mit seinen Vorstellungen nochmal in die Verlängerung.
Bei ihm könnte es fast auch noch auf den Elfmeterschießen hinauslaufen.
Ja, es könnte auch einfach sein, dass er da, weil der Technik so weit voraus
ist, dass er einfach im Abseits steht.
Ja, das ist gut vorstellbar.
Also da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass da der Offizielle nochmal an den Stand
der Technik erinnern muss.
Und die Kompetenz nach weiß, würde ich sagen, ist auch schon sehr nah an der gelben Karte.
Ja, könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass da nochmal eine dritte Halbzeit kommt.
Also das ist das, ja.
Vor der Verwarnung steht die Ermahnung, die sprechen wir hiermit aus.
Genau. Ich würde...
Denk nochmal drüber nach.
Ich würde...
Gerne nochmal darauf hinweisen, wir haben ja gesagt, es geht um das Einführen
einer AI-basierten Überwachung auf den Endgeräten, die dann automatisch Treffer meldet.
Potenziell gibt es ein derartiges Setup bei Facebook und Instagram,
die haben das schon und wir diskutieren das ja deshalb, weil im Prinzip Instagram
keine sichere Kommunikation anbietet.
Und das dort zu machen ist schon in Anführungszeichen uncool genug,
aber jetzt einen verschlüsselten Messenger,
der, wenn wir jetzt das Beispiel Signal nehmen, weltweit für Unmengen an legitimen
Anwendungszwecken verwendet wird.
Also nicht nur im privaten Bereich, sondern da geht es ja dann auch um,
also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Menschen, die in der Ukraine,
im Gaza-Streifen oder sonst wo unterwegs sind oder in Israel,
Wo auch in vielen Krisenregionen dieser Erde mitunter auch sehr wichtige Inhalte
über diese Messenger schicken und darauf vertrauen müssen, dass die vertraulich sind.
Da geht es also nicht nur immer um unsere, um unser bisschen konsensuelle Schlüffrigkeiten,
die wir da hin und her schicken, Tim.
Und dieser so dieses Setup bei Facebook, Instagram die melden.
Also ich nehme da Facebook und Instagram als Beispiel, die melden an das NECMEC,
NECMEC, National Center for Missing and Exploiting Children.
Und das NECMEC meldet dann weiter zum Beispiel auch an das BKA.
Also in bestimmten Bereichen gibt es das also schon.
Und jetzt schauen wir uns mal da die Statistiken an. Da hat das NECMEC 2022
136 mutmaßliche Fälle an das BKA gemeldet. 136 merken.
Und von diesen 136.000 waren 90.000 tatsächlich strafrechtlich relevant und 46.000 nicht.
Also wenn man das jetzt grob mischt, zwei Drittel relevant, ein Drittel nicht.
Im Jahr 2023 ist diese Statistik auf 180.000 gestiegen, also von 136.000 auf 180.000.
Das ist ungefähr ein Drittel mehr insgesamt.
Aber die Zahl strafrechtlich relevanter Fälle ist nicht mitgestiegen,
sondern die ist gesunken.
Das heißt, wir haben wieder 89.000 tatsächliche strafrechtlich relevante Fälle,
obwohl die Gesamtzahl der Meldungen sich erhöht hat und wer jetzt so richtig
einen auf Adam Riese gemacht hat, weiß,
die falschen Verdächtigungen haben sich verdoppelt.
Von 46.000 auf knapp 91.000.
Also es gibt mal wieder mehr Heu. Wir hatten eine Welt, in der ein Drittel Falschverdächtigungen
waren und wir haben jetzt eine Welt, in der 50% Falschverdächtigungen waren.
Das ist also nicht besonders gut.
Also zwei Jahre allein reichen jetzt natürlich auch noch nicht für eine finale
Bestätigung, aber hier ist natürlich schon mal ein klarer Trend zu sehen.
Die Zahl der Falschverdächtigungen gering zu halten, ist genauso wichtig.
Weil du möchtest nicht, also jede Falschverdächtigung heißt,
eine Kette an Menschen hat sich das angeschaut.
Beim Nack-Mack eine automatische Meldung, weitergegeben ans BKA.
BKA, jede dieser Dinge hat irgendwo ein Mensch reingeguckt und gesagt,
nee, okay, das war falsch.
90.000 Fälle, wo das BKA nur bei Facebook und Instagram reingeschaut hat und
gesagt hat, hier erhärtet sich aber der Verdacht nicht. Das ist jetzt nicht ein Randphänomen.
Im Prinzip kannst du sagen, die Systeme haben eine Trefferquote von 50%. Münzwurf.
Stimmt nicht ganz, aber wenn das Ding etwas ist, jetzt kannst du natürlich nicht
wissen, wie viel die nicht erkannt haben, aber üblicherweise,
wenn ein System bei positiver Erkennung nur 50% Trefferwahrscheinlichkeit hat,
kannst du eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass das sehr sensitiv ist und Dinge erkennt
und sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dass ihm noch irgendetwas entgeht,
weil den anderen Fehler macht es ja offenbar nicht.
Würde ich auch, dass die.
Detektionsrate gleich bleibt, dass du jeweils so 89.000 hast,
würde ich sagen, das ist dann eventuell, also wenn das nicht mitsteigt,
aber deine Fehldetektion, dann hast du was an deinem Messinstrument kaputt.
Naja, es ist wirklich keine gute Idee und wir sind jetzt mal gespannt,
wie sich die Länder weiter verhalten, wenn jetzt Belgien übernimmt.
Frankreich schien irgendwie zu wackeln.
Wenn Ungarn übernimmt, meinst du?
Entschuldigung, natürlich. Belgien abgibt und Ungarn übernimmt.
Frankreich schien zu wackeln.
Tschechien hatte gesagt, sie wollen sich enthalten. Irland wollte dafür stimmen.
Es wird jetzt eigentlich, muss Deutschland sich jetzt mal Mühe geben,
da wieder mal dafür zu werben, dass sie sich auch mal vernünftig verhalten.
Dazu fordert Patrick Breyer, klar, keine verdachtlose Chatkontrolle,
die Verschlüsselung muss geschützt sein und zwar richtig geschützt sein,
Anonymität muss geschützt sein, es geht ja immer noch in diesem Kontext auch
um die verpflichtende Altersüberprüfung und keine App-Zensur für junge Menschen,
weil da ja auch Überlegungen waren,
quasi anhand des Alters anders vorzugehen.
Ich glaube, dass das alles hier so eine Kanonen-auf-Spatzen-Debatte ist und
wenn wir uns die wirklichen Erfolge der Strafverfolgungsbehörden in dem Kontext
anschauen und da sind ja welche und da sind auch wirklich zunehmende,
da geht es immer um ganz andere Infrastrukturen, die da genutzt werden als verschlüsselte Messenger.
Aber denkt nicht, dass das Thema jetzt vorbei wäre. Geht weiter.
Ja klar, also Chat-Controller ist damit noch nicht wirklich vom Tisch,
aber es zeigt sich zumindest, dass es schwierig ist, hier in Europa einen Konsens
zu erzeugen für eine solche Regelung.
Und wie gesagt, also mein Tipp ist, Ungarn wird da keine großen Fortschritte
machen, weil die im Zweifelsfall zu extrem an die Sache rangehen,
aber das wird sich natürlich dann erst noch zeigen, was weiß ich.
Gut, kommen wir zu einem anderen Problem. Du würdest mir ja sicherlich zustimmen,
unsere Bürokratie hat es schwer und muss dringend entlastet werden.
Also das ist ja wirklich offensichtlich.
Und würdest mir auch zustimmen, dass das Reiseerlebnis des Fluggastes verbessert
werden muss. Du bist ja auch bisweilen fliegend unterwegs.
Das eine oder andere Mal, ja.
Ja, was ist denn die größte Spaßbremse auf dem Flughafen für dich?
Woran müsste denn mal wirklich gearbeitet werden?
Die Leute, die an der Schlange vorbeigehen und versuchen, deinen Koffer zu wiegen,
um irgendwie dich zu terrorisieren, dass du den doch noch eincheckst.
Also häufiger?
Also normalerweise trauen die sich nicht an mich ran, aber ich hatte letztens
tatsächlich dieses Erlebnis.
Und was soll ich sagen?
Die würde ich wegrationalisieren.
Die würdest du wegrationalisieren. Naja, das ist ein Problemfeld,
was die Politik noch nicht erkannt hat. Es tut mir jetzt sehr leid, dass ich das sagen muss.
Achso, und übrigens auch die abreißenden Türen an den Boeing-Flugzeugen,
die würde ich auch wegrationalisieren.
Das ist jetzt mein Vorschlag. Aber das wären jetzt so meine Grenzen.
Was könnte man noch machen?
Bisschen bessere Champagner-Auswahl in der Lounge, aber sonst...
Die wahren Krisen werden wieder von der Politik nicht erfasst,
denn unsere Bundesregierung ist dabei,
einen weiteren Vorschlag beraten zu lassen, der sich derzeit so in der Ausschussberatung
befindet, im Bundestag und im Bundesrat.
Und das vierte Bürokratie-Entlastungsgesetz sieht nämlich unter anderem Änderungen
am Pass als auch im Luftverkehrsgesetz vor,
die es privaten Unternehmen am Flughafen ermöglichen würden,
deinen Reisepass nicht so nur wie bisher optisch auszulesen,
sondern auch tatsächlich an den Chip ranzugehen, indem die biometrischen Informationen
über dich ausgelöst werden.
Abgespeichert sind, sprich das biometrische Gesichtsbild.
Und der Hintergrund ist der, dass man das als ein großes Problem angesehen hat,
dass man ja beim Check-in so lange Zeit damit braucht, dich zu überprüfen.
Also,
nicht der Fall. Nicht der Fall. Also, okay, ich wollte eigentlich nicht so viel
drüber reden, aber fliegen, ne?
Mir ist es durch eine Verwirrung tatsächlich dummerweise gelungen,
für mich selber zweimal den gleichen Flug zu buchen.
Du hast zwei Tickets.
Ich habe zwei Tickets gehabt. Ich konnte mich einmal vorne hinsetzen und einmal in der Mitte.
Wow.
Ich bin da halt durcheinander gekommen. Weißt du, was das Problem war?
Ich kenne das, das passiert ja jedem mal.
Das passiert jedem mal. Es war tatsächlich so, dass die, also es war ein Lufthansa-Flug
und der, ich habe einfach nicht die Bestätigung bekommen und dieser Buchungsvorgang
ist so irgendwo in so einem Nirvana gelandet.
Und du musstest aber unbedingt da rein. Dann habe ich eine halbe Stunde gewartet,
ich habe weder eine E-Mail bekommen, noch eine Bestätigung im Browser,
dachte ich so, naja, okay, dann wird das jetzt ausgeidelt sein.
Ich hatte aber die Abbuchung auf der Kreditkarte und da war es natürlich jetzt
unklug von mir, aber ich wollte auch nicht riskieren, dass ich nachher nicht
genau diesen Flug kriege und dann konnte ich den problemlos,
gleiche Name, gleiche Profil, ein zweites Mal buchen.
Also es ist denen furzegal, wie viele Plätze du buchst.
Also eine nette Airline hätte ja gesagt, Junge, meinst du echt, dass du da rein musst?
Das ist aber wirklich interessant, also dass das überhaupt geht.
Natürlich geht das, es ist denen auch scheißegal. Hauptsache du bezahlst.
Niemand kontrolliert deinen Ausweis, außer die Asi-Airlines,
die verhindern wollen und die machen das nur für eine Zweitmarktkontrolle.
Die einzigen Leute, die an einem Flughafen deine, wirklich mit einem richtigen
Interesse, deinen Ausweis oder deinen Pass kontrollieren, sind die Leute an der Immigration.
Wenn du irgendwie durch Europa fliegst, interessiert sich niemand für deinen
Ausweis, außer Asijet und Ryanair.
Und die machen das, weil sie sicherstellen wollen, dass du nicht die Tickets
aufkaufst und die irgendwo auf Ebay teurer verkaufst. Das ist alles.
Schengen gilt auch weiterhin.
Das ist absoluter Quatsch. Also, nee, das gibt's nicht.
Wurde auf jeden Fall von der Politik als echtes Problem erkannt.
Ja, von der Politik. Weißt du, ich versuch, Junge, weißt du,
seit wie vielen Monaten ich versuch, einen Termin im scheiß Bürgeramt in Berlin zu bekommen?
Und jetzt entlasten die, also ich mein, wenn das hier mit diesem Pass,
egal was sie da vorhaben, wenn das funktioniert, müsste ich ja erstmal so einen Pass bekommen.
Ja, also Ziel soll auf jeden Fall sein, die Prozesse der Passagierabfertigung
an Flughäfen zu beschleunigen, damit das Reiseerlebnis des Fluggastes verbessert wird.
Und der Move, der dadurch jetzt durch diese vorgeschlagenen Änderungen aber vollzogen wird,
bedeutet faktisch, dass ein bisher ausschließlich behördlicher Vorgang,
nämlich das Auslesen dieses Chips, jetzt auch kommerziellen Unternehmen,
also privaten, erlaubt wird.
Also insofern kann man das auch als Dammbruch bezeichnen, weil 2005,
als das alles eingeführt wurde, wurde halt explizit gesagt, naja,
ist aber nur für Terrorismusbekämpfung und das dürfen ja auch nur offizielle Stellen,
also Polizei,
Zoll, etc.
Hey, man könnte einfach sagen, Bürokratieentlastung, die sollen aufhören mit dem Quatsch.
Weil was die machen ist, du gehst da hin, dann hältst du dein iPhone oder dein,
Google-freies Android-Phone auf diesen Scanner und dann steht bei denen auf
dem Bildschirm ein Name, dann gucken die, welcher Name da steht und dann sagen
die, halt mal bitte deinen Ausweis hin und gucken, dass da auch dein Name steht.
Das ist vollkommen ausreichend für deren Interessen und wenn sie das nicht wollen,
dann sollen sie halt damit aufhören.
Das wäre halt mal eine Entlastung zu sagen, identifiziert nicht Leute,
wo es nicht notwendig ist. Das wäre Bürokratieentlastung.
Ja, es ist eh Quatsch, weil innerhalb von Schengen ist halt diese Reisepassprüfung
gar nicht erforderlich.
Das heißt, da muss auch niemand entlastet werden bei der Polizei,
weil die das dann eh nicht tun müssen.
Und ansonsten geht es ja hier darum, dass quasi so das Check-In-Erlebnis irgendwie
verbessert werden soll.
Das ist ein Quatsch Also es haben sich verschiedene Entitäten gemeldet natürlich
jetzt hier zu diesem Prozess,
unter anderem Datenschutzkapitän Kelber und natürlich auch der CCC in Form von Cantorkel,
der hier die schöne Formulierung gefunden hat.
Die neue biometrische Fluggastabfertigung soll bei einer geschätzten Fallzahl
von knapp 38 Millionen privaten Flugreisen genutzt werden.
Werden erwartet, wird laut des Entwurfs eine Zeiteinsparung von einer Minute
pro Fluggast, die aber eine Schätzung ist. Ob Passagiere dann 120...
Geile Schätzung!
Guck mal, in so ein Flugzeug gehen 100, was sind das?
180 Leute, sind nur normalen.
Hast du irgendwie 36 rein oder sowas in der langen Variante mal 6 Leute,
also sagen wir 180 Leute. Ja?
Wenn du da eine Minute pro Fluggast sparen könntest, dann wären wir heute in
einer Welt, in der es drei Stunden dauert, dieses Flugzeug zu befüllen.
Ich halte das für irgendwie nicht...
Nicht realistisch.
Nicht realistisch, die Schätzung. Gut, geben wir zu, teilweise lassen die durch
zwei oder drei Gates rein, dann wären wir also bei, aber das ist scheiße.
Genau, also Kantoin gefügt noch an, ob Passagiere dann statt 120 Minuten nur
noch 119 Minuten vor Abflug am Flughafen sein müssen, geht aus dem Entwurf nicht direkt hervor.
Also es ist ja auch ein bisschen unklar.
Was jetzt hier eigentlich wirklich gelöst werden soll Und de facto würde es.
Halt bedeuten, dass man jetzt eigentlich überhaupt erstmal ein neues Risiko schafft.
Es gibt da zwar Risikominimierungsvorschläge vom BSI, was von Herrn Kelber auch
anerkannt wird, allerdings meint er halt auch, das Risiko entsteht aber auch
erst dadurch, dass das jetzt überhaupt so erlaubt wird.
Und es gab vor allem im Oktober bereits schon eine Neufassung der Gesetze dahingehend,
dass halt mittlerweile diese Beschränkung auf Polizei, Zoll und Meldebehörden
ohnehin schon weggefallen ist.
Das heißt der Zugriff ist mittlerweile für alle Behörden möglich. Wirklich.
Nur jetzt käme dann eben der nächste Schritt, womit dann eben auch privat drauf zugreifen kann.
Und ehrlich gesagt, dieses Argument mit Flughafenbeschleunigung und so weiter
sehe ich halt nicht, weil das auch ohnehin so formuliert ist,
dass die biometrische Erfassung dann quasi vor Ort wäre.
Also die stellen sich das so vor, dass man dann am Check-in nochmal quasi gefilmt
wird, so wie das heute bei diesen automatischen Passkontrollen ist und dann
eigentlich in dem Moment dann ein neues biometrisches Bild quasi erst aufgenommen
wird, was dann im weiteren Prozess gemacht wird.
Aber ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was das beschleunigen soll oder was das verhindern soll.
Also die Lufthansa will das tatsächlich,
also die haben das auch, also die bewerben das aktiv, dass sie irgendwie sagen,
lass mal irgendwie einen Biometrie-Scan machen, dann kommst du noch schneller
ins Flugzeug, was ja auch so, geil,
ich bin noch länger in der Scheißröhre, ja, also das ist ja irgendwie so…,
Also ich kann wirklich nicht, also das, gut,
also man könnte argumentieren, also ich würde sagen, die durchschnittliche Person
braucht wahrscheinlich sowas wie, ich würde irgendwas zwischen 7 und 13 Sekunden
den Durchschnitt schätzen, den eine Person braucht, um da mit ihrem Handy einmal kurz vorbeizugehen.
Weil jeder So-und-So-Vierte weiß nicht genau, wo sein Handy ist und so,
oh shit, die Schlange, wo ich jetzt...
Du redest jetzt vom Boarding oder vom Check-In?
Vom Boarding, ja.
Vom Boarding, genau.
Ein Check-In ist doch eh egal.
Eben. Also ein Check-In wird natürlich teilweise, ist ja gar nicht mehr erforderlich,
in dem Sinne, du machst ja dein Check-In sowieso online meistens.
Du musst es dann vielleicht nochmal nachweisen, wenn du dein Gepäck abgeben
willst, aber auch das ist mittlerweile schon automatisiert.
Auch da reicht der normale Scan des Ausweises, weil es nicht relevant ist,
dass du da jetzt direkt mit deinem Gesicht davor stehst.
Ich sehe ja auch eher noch Probleme durch nicht funktionierende Chips oder weitere Komplikationen.
Es kommt ja alles noch dazu.
Dieses ganze Ausrichten, sich ordentlich nochmal biometrisch abfilmen lassen
und vor allem wofür. Also ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo da der Gewinn ist.
Also Kälber sagt, gehen wir mal davon aus, es gäbe da einen Gewinn.
Dann hat Kantorke ja schon sehr gut gesagt, muss man dann nur 119 Minuten vorher
da sein, ist schon mal sehr gut.
Aber was Kälber dazu auch sagt, die Freigabe würde einen gänzlich neuen Verarbeitungszweck
bereits für die Erhebung und Speicherung der Daten auf dem Chip für kommerzielle Zwecke begründen.
Also da quasi erlauben, das heißt, das wäre der Dammbruch zu kommerzieller Nutzung
der biometrischen Daten und das ist halt absoluter Irrsinn.
Also muss man jetzt mal schauen, wie das läuft. Ich halte die Einwände für berechtigt
und deswegen ist das glaube ich keine gute Idee und die Bundesregierung würde gut daran tun,
diesen Passus einfach zu streichen, weil das halt einfach nur Ärger bringt und
keinen wirklich erkennbaren Vorteil.
Und dann muss man sich wieder mit Missbrauch rumschlagen, weil klar,
die sollen halt die Daten sofort wieder löschen. Ja, genau.
Das funktioniert. Vor allem ist es ja sogar einfacher dann zu sagen,
da nimmt halt nicht die Passdaten, bietet halt diese Speedways an.
Also wenn ich in München am Hauptbahnhof, nein am Flugbahnhof in München mein
Portemonnaie suche, dann gehe ich ja auch,
steige ich ja quasi am Flughafen in den Zug ein. Nein.
Da gibt es diese Pass-Terminals, wo du, du kannst entweder mit Menschen interagieren
oder mit diesen, da gehe ich auch durch so ein biometrisches Ding.
Die sind schon auch relativ zügig, aber ehrlich gesagt, an den Dingern hänge
ich länger als woanders. Wenn jemand privat etwas solches machen möchte,
dann sollen die halt privat diese Daten sammeln.
Dann soll die Lufthansa halt sagen, wir machen hier eine biometrische Datensammlung
und dann sagt auch jeder, nee, will ich nicht.
Ich will keine Lufthansa-Daten-Biometrie. Ich möchte mein Handy zücken und in
das Flugzeug gehen und ich möchte, dass das ankommt und die Tür nicht abfällt.
Das sind die Hauptbedürfnisse des Kunden.
Das ist ja auch hier ein privater Beschleunigungszweck.
Nehmen wir mal an, der wäre gegeben, dass der sich jetzt an eine staatliche
Infrastruktur hängen will. Das ist alles absurd.
Also ich habe ja überhaupt nichts gegen eine Verbesserung meines Reiseerlebnisses,
wenn ich schon mal am Flughafen bin, aber ich glaube die einzige wirklich,
also die signifikanteste und beste und sinnvollste Verbesserung dieses Reiseerlebnisses,
die ich bisher erlebt habe, kommt ausgerechnet am BERA, findet die Stadt,
dass man sich da vorher ein Termin… Nicht sagen.
Nicht sagen, nicht sagen, nicht sagen, nicht sagen, nicht sagen!
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Echt, das ist, das ist… Wenn.
Die anderen das erfahren.
Ja, genau, man kann So, dann gibt es Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema Kommen wir
zum nächsten Thema Das kannst du nicht sagen,
Digital Wallet. Wir bleiben im Identifikationsbereich. Wir möchten ja unsere
digitale Souveränität wahren.
Wir möchten unsere digitale Souveränität wahren. Was ist eigentlich unsere digitale Souveränität?
Wir möchten unsere Unabhängigkeit von einzelnen Anbietern und Produkten erhalten
als Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Und in diesem Zwecke, in diesem Sinne möchten
wir dann für mehr Datenschutz und IT-Sicherheit suchen, wenn wir staatliche
Infrastrukturen bauen.
Zum Beispiel im Identifikationsbereich.
Klingt schön.
Um das neue Neue digitale Wallet und Thomas hatte das hier am Rande auch schon
erwähnt, dass dort in Deutschland jetzt ein partizipativer Wettbewerb stattfinden soll,
bei der Auslobung, welche Architektur und Implementierung für dieses digitale
Wallet in Deutschland gewinnen soll.
Das ist ein Innovationswettbewerb, wo jetzt Prototypen für ein deutsches Wallet gebaut werden.
Dieser Wettbewerb läuft insgesamt 13 Monate, hat drei Phasen.
Also ungefähr im Mai 2025 wird da die Gewinnerin gekürt.
Die ersten beiden Phasen sind jeweils drei Monate, die letzte Phase sind sechs
Monate und in den ersten beiden Phasen kriegst du jeweils 300.000 Euro und in der letzten 350. 950.
Also du bewirbst dich da jetzt für diesen Innovationswettbewerb,
dann gibt es insgesamt drei Phasen, wenn du es bis in die letzte Phase schaffst,
950.000 Euro Förderung und du musst dann eben am Ende müssen alle ihre Prototypen
als Open Source veröffentlichen.
Der Quellcode kann dann also auch von Dritten eingesehen und geändert werden
und das klingt ehrlich gesagt nach einer, muss man jetzt einfach mal sagen,
ganz coolen Idee für so ein Projekt.
Dass man sagt, okay, wir haben hier eine gewisse Anforderung,
wir machen jetzt einen Wettbewerb, aber wir machen nicht so einen klassischen
Wettbewerb, Winner takes it all,
sondern wir lassen die mal in mehreren Phasen gegeneinander antreten,
wir fanden die, hören irgendwann vielleicht auf, die zu fanden,
alles muss Open Source sein.
Ist jetzt erstmal von der Herangehensweise, würde ich sagen,
das ist schon mal nicht so schlecht.
Hat vor allem für beide Seiten was Gutes. Man muss jetzt nicht für lau da arbeiten
und steht dann mit nichts mehr da auf der einen Seite.
Auf der anderen Seite wissen aber auch alle, sie stehen zu diesem Zeitpunkt
auch schon noch immer im Wettbewerb mit anderen und müssen technisch da auch etwas liefern,
damit sie am Ende, wenn sie wirklich mal bewiesen haben im Idealfall,
dass das ein gutes Konzept ist und alle Anforderungen erfüllt,
dass man da dann eben auch die finale Strecke dann alleine machen darf.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass die sich für ihre 300.000 Euro sehr viel Mühe
geben, um die nächsten 300.000 Euro zu kriegen.
Genau und das ist halt auch ein ganz guter Incentive, auch gute Arbeit zu leisten
und das kann am Ende alle glücklich machen.
Das finde ich gut. Das ist ein guter Ansatz.
Man könnte ja auch argumentieren, oh da wird aber jetzt so viel Geld ausgegeben
am Anfang für Arbeit, die am Ende nichts macht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich viel teurer, Kohle in irgendeine Firma,
die überhaupt gar keinen Druck mehr hat zu investieren.
Das haben wir oft genug gesehen, weil die dann einfach drauf scheißen kann auf die Qualität.
Ja, also absolut, stimme ich absolut zu und vor allem, wenn es Open Source sein muss,
dann kann potenziell, wenn jetzt irgendein, sagen wir mal, was weiß ich,
da setzt sich jetzt eine Gruppe durch, die macht 70% echt optimal und eine Gruppe
macht 70% der Anforderungen und die andere Gruppe macht irgendwas anderes gut,
dann kannst du potenziell irgendwann sagen,
ey Gruppe A, ihr habt jetzt gewonnen, aber ihr müsst bitte den anderen Kram,
die haben das hier intelligenter gelöst oder so.
Also, ich glaube, eine relativ kluge Idee der Ausschreibung.
So, jetzt werden einige Leute bemerkt haben, wir gehen über den...
Den tatsächlichen Zweck, dass hier halt ein digitales Wallet ausgeschrieben
wird und so gehen wir gerade mal ein bisschen hinweg.
Da gibt es eine ganz eigene Kritik dran, die spielt jetzt gerade,
also die spielt eine Rolle, die halten wir nur jetzt hier mal gerade außen vor,
weil es um was anderes geht insgesamt.
So, jetzt haben da sehr viele drauf geboten, jetzt wurden die ersten sechs bekannt
gegeben, die quasi diese Förderung bekommen in der ersten Runde,
die 300.000, das sind sechs Unternehmen. nehmen.
Außerdem, achso, sollte man dazu sagen, diesen Wettbewerb, diesen Bieterwettbewerb oder,
partizipative Innovationswettbewerb, wie auch immer du das jetzt nennst,
da gibt's dann, wurde ausgelobt, außerdem noch die Einbeziehung der Zivilgesellschaft.
Und das hatte Thomas hier als er letztes Mal bei uns zu Gast war auch erwähnt,
dass er dort in dieser Jury ist.
Einer von vielen, die Jury ist relativ groß und die gehostet wird das ganze Ding von der Sprint.
Der Sprung-Innovations-Agentur Deutschland oder was das da ist.
Auch das ja mit relativ wenig Geld versehen ist, aber auch keine fundamental
schlechte Idee, sich mal darum zu kümmern, dass man irgendwie versucht,
Innovation in Deutschland zu fördern.
Also das ganze Ding, vom Konzept her klingt das alles nicht so doof.
So, natürlich wird die EIDAS-Reform von Datenschützerinnen und Bürgerrechtlerinnen
die ganze Zeit kritisiert. Das ist die rechtliche Grundlage für dieses Wallet
und entsprechend diese Kritik geht erstmal weiterhin.
Wir haben sie jetzt nur gerade nicht das zentrale Thema.
Es gibt natürlich weiterhin die Befürchtung.
Dass hier Unternehmensinteressen einfließen, deswegen auch dieses Einbeziehung
der Zivilgesellschaft in diesen Bieterprozess.
So, jetzt haben sie sechs bekannt gegeben, die die Förderung bekommen und außerdem
haben sie fünf bekannt gegeben, die nicht finanziell gefördert werden,
aber weiter das Feedback der Jury bekommen und vom Netzwerk,
das sich dort ergeben hat, von Sprint profitieren sollen.
Wer sitzt da mit drin? Samsung und Google.
Weil die haben sich natürlich nicht beworben. Also Samsung bewirbt sich nicht
für 300.000 Euro für Sprunginnovation oder so.
Und Google auch nicht. Aber was die natürlich tun ist, zu sagen,
wir sind Google übrigens, wir haben da so ein kleines Open-Source-Betriebssystem
für Mobilgeräte mit 70-80% Marktanteil, könnt ihr euch interessieren?
Und Samsung sagt, wir sind Samsung übrigens, diese Geräte, die es da gibt.
Von denen bauen wir, weiß ich nicht,
von denen 70, 80 Prozent Marktanteil stellen wir 70, 80 Prozent her.
Wollt ihr mit uns reden? Wir haben übrigens auch Ideen, wie man so ein ID-Kram
machen kann, weil wir uns damit ja auch auseinandersetzen und letztendlich sind
wir die Hardware- und die Software-Plattform, auf der ihr am Ende eh landen müsst.
Und jetzt ist natürlich, das ist natürlich du kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen,
wie dann so diese Deutsche-Deutschland-Souveränitäts- Sprintjury da sitzt und sagt, ah, fuck,
wir wollten eigentlich hier einen auf Sprunginnovation und digitale Souveränität
und so weiter machen und jetzt sitzt ihr da.
Gleichzeitig müssen sie ja.
Irgendwie auch was Realisierbares machen, das geht nicht ohne die.
Also man kann sich wirklich vorstellen, wie die da sitzen.
Du hast halt jetzt mit deinem digitalen Souveränitätsprojekt,
was die wichtigste souveräne Aufgabe überhaupt angeht, nämlich Identifikation
auszustellen, um am Ende die ganzen Daten der Lufthansa zu geben,
damit du eine Minute schneller ins Flugzeug kommst.
Das ist wirklich, also as sovereign as it gets.
Und dann sitzen da Google und Samsung und sagen, so stellen wir uns das vor
und du bist gezwungen zu sagen,
scheiße, ich meine, die haben wahrscheinlich da mehr Budget hinter als ganz
Bundesrepublik Deutschland überhaupt und die können das in allen Ländern anbieten
und du kommst sowieso nicht an denen vorbei.
Wobei, es sei denn, du machst einfach ein NPA, wie wir es schon haben.
Nur das nochmal als kleine Fundamentalkritik, wir haben das ja alles schon,
deswegen können wir ja auch jetzt schon die Daten der Lufthansa schenken oder
verkaufen und müssen nicht mehr auf diese Eudi warten.
Aber ja, du kannst dir ungefähr den Schmerz vorstellen, der da jetzt herrscht.
Es gibt, das Google Team sagt, unser Ziel ist es sicherzustellen,
dass alle Wallet-Anwendungen ein robustes und qualitativ hochwertiges Nutzererlebnis
bieten und gleichzeitig starke Sicherheits- und Privatsphäre-Eigenschaften aufweisen.
Unsere Ziele in diesem Projekt sind der Aufbau einer Referenz-Wallet-Implementierung
unter Verwendung von Android und Chrome Best Practices für Wallet-Entwickler
in Deutschland und der gesamten EU.
Wir werden eine vollständig quellöffene Referenz-Wallet-Implementierung bereitstellen,
die auf unserer bestehenden Open-Source-Wallet, der Open-Wallet-Foundation, basiert.
Darüber hinaus wollen wir modernste Innovationen in der Kryptografie und sichere
Hardware auf dem Gerät demonstrieren. Ja, klar wollt ihr das.
Und im Zweifelsfall braucht ihr dafür nicht die 300.000 Euro und im Zweifelsfall
habt ihr vieles davon schon in der Tasche.
Also ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich mich dazu jetzt...
Verhalten soll, weil klar ist, dass das nicht ohne Android und Samsung und am
Ende auch iOS gehen wird, irgendwie so ein Wallet zu implementieren.
Man könnte auch zu dem Punkt kommen, deswegen macht man es nicht.
Also ich glaube, ich habe meine Meinung dazu schon ein paar Mal genannt.
Ich denke, alles, was mit ID und Bezahlen zu tun hat, so und Wallet heißt ja
im Prinzip Ausweise für allen möglichen Kram,
also diese ganze Autorisierung gegenüber Dritten, muss meiner Auffassung nach
etwas sein, was tief in Betriebssystemen verankert sein muss.
Klar, du kommst nicht an denen vorbei.
Ist glaube ich unvermeidlich und hätte eigentlich schon auf europäischer Ebene laufen müssen.
Also man kann jetzt Google da gar nicht vorwerfen, dass sie da überhaupt ein
Interesse daran haben, weil sie im Zweifelsfall das halt auch so sehen und sagen
so, ja, nee, das muss aber hier ins Betriebssystem.
Sie wollen doch nur helfen. Sie wollen doch nur die beste User Experience.
Das kann sogar stimmen.
Ich meine, erinnere dich, all diese ganzen Lösungen, die immer versuchen,
irgendwas hoheitliches auf App-Ebene zu lösen, sind einfach alles Katastrophen.
Es ist schon auch, also man muss auch sagen, das ist vielleicht ganz gut,
dass wir da jetzt so eine Luftbrücke haben, die uns hilft irgendwie.
So Digitalisierungs-Care-Pakete.
Das wäre schön. Die Digitalisierungs-Luftbrücke aus den USA.
Aber es ist auch klar, dass das halt irgendwie einfach ein absolutes Desaster ist.
Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, du musst jetzt dann irgendwie da hingehen und
sagen, hier ist deine neue ID-Wallet von Google.
Naja, es reicht mir ja, wenn sie die Standards definieren und dann muss halt
klar gesagt werden, das ist das, was die Betriebssysteme machen müssen,
das ist die API, die wir bereitstellen.
Genau deswegen hätte man niemals in diese Richtung sich bewegen sollen.
Bitte wer sich nicht in welche Richtung bewegen soll.
Ich will jetzt nicht die Debatte aufmachen, aber wir haben ja einen Personalausweis,
der viele Funktionalitäten, die man da braucht und definiert und so weiter unterstützt
und dem wir leider nie auf der anderen Seite Angebote gemacht haben,
außer hol mal Punktestand in Flensburg ab oder irgendwas mit der Steuer.
Oh ja, das ist diese ganze Leuchtturm-Thematik.
Aber ich wollte, also, man hätte sich das vorher denken können,
dass man genau in diese Falle läuft und jetzt sitzt die Jury da und kann weder
sagen, wir wollen ohne Google machen, noch wir wollen mit Google machen.
Und alle haben gesagt, hier machen wir mal digitale Souveränität.
Und jetzt sitzen sie genau in
der Falle, wo man weiß, dass die mit einem solchen Projekt einfach kommt.
Naja gut, man kann auch souverän bleiben, wenn man halt einfach die Standards
dann so macht, dass sie in Betriebssystemen zwar implementiert werden können,
aber in dem Sinne jetzt von jedem Betriebssystemhersteller implementiert werden können.
Ja, da hat Google ja keine Sorge, dass ihr Standard so umgesetzt wird.
Lustiges Ding, wir haben dann demnächst mal gucken, ob wir dann auch irgendwie
so Consent-Banner auf unserer IT-Wallet haben und Tracking und so weiter.
Ich glaube, das wird noch eine Weile dauern alles.
Es gibt eine gute Nachricht, wir haben hier öfter darüber berichtet.
Dass bei Radio Dreieckland in Freiburg eine Hausdurchsuchung war,
weil die im Rahmen ihrer Berichterstattung auf das Archiv von links unten in
die Media verlinkt hatten, um da den Kontext herzustellen.
Und ihr erinnert euch, dass es da dann die Beschuldigung gab,
dass sie diese verbotene Vereinigung unterstützt haben, dadurch,
dass sie diese Internetseite verlinkt haben.
Also mit dem Verlinken dieser Internetseite wurde weiteres Handeln dieser verbotenen
Vereinigung unterstützt.
Dieses weitere Handeln stimmt aber natürlich nicht, weil es handelte sich ja
um das Archiv, also nicht um etwas, was da noch weiter geht.
Also völlig absurder Fall, der dann jetzt auch vorm Gericht mit einem Freispruch
stattfand und zwar relativ einfach.
Man kann keine Vereinigung bewerben, die nicht mehr existiert.
Und diese Vereinigung gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Ja, und man konnte eben, niemand konnte in der Vereinigung, in der Verhandlung
nachweisen, dass diese Organisation überhaupt noch existiert.
Sie ist ja schließlich verboten.
Ja, und deswegen kannst du die auch nicht mehr bewerben, weil die gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Und da beißt, also ich meine, das war ja ohnehin ein vollkommen absurder,
also ein vollkommen absurdes Vorgehen, überhaupt die Webseite quasi,
den Betrieb der Webseite zu verbieten, indem man die Betreiber als.
Verbotene Organisation einstuft, auch das eine absolute Farce,
ja und dann gegen Journalistinnen vorzugehen, die auf dieser Archivseite verlinken,
wie es übrigens nicht vergessen,
dass BKA und so weiter selber gemacht haben, die haben ja selber auf Twitter dorthin gelinkt,
die hat keiner angezeigt und jetzt halt quasi dieses gesamte juristische Fantasiekonstrukt
ist jetzt eben da gestolpert.
Hat und gescheitern, ist auch genau richtig.
Es gab noch ein weiteres Urteil, das wir gerne besprechen würden und das ist
gar nicht so uninteressant.
Und zwar ist das ein Urteil des Landgerichts Köln.
Gar nicht so weit weg und so fern, aber ich fand tatsächlich die Berichterstattung
darüber sehr erkenntnisreich.
Also, verurteilt wurde Meta, die müssen 20 Millionen Euro an die Deutsche Telekom nachzahlen.
So, wofür müssen die nachzahlen? Ja, und zwar für Rechnungen,
die die Deutsche Telekom denen geschickt hat, die sich seit drei Jahren angesammelt
haben und die Meta nicht bezahlt hat. So.
Wie kommt es, dass Meta Rechnungen von der Deutschen Telekom nicht bezahlt?
Naja, seit 2010 hatte Meta IP Transit über private Interconnects.
24 Stück an der Zahl. Also ein Interconnect ist da, wo sich jetzt Meta direkt
mit der Deutschen Telekom verbindet.
Üblicherweise würdest du das…,
Nicht unbedingt tun oder du würdest einfach vielleicht in Frankfurt über den D-Kicks gehen,
wo du dann einfach grundsätzlich Internet bekommst, aber
es gab eben offenbar hier seit 2010 direkte Vereinbarungen zwischen der Deutschen
Telekom und Meta an 24 privaten Interconnects direkt quasi Übergabepunkte zwischen
Meta und der Deutschen Telekom zu haben.
Man muss sich einfach klar machen, Unternehmen wie Meta mit Facebook und so
weiter, genauso wie Google auch,
sind so groß, die haben einfach ihre eigenen Netzwerkinfrastrukturen überall
in der Welt und gehen nicht von ihrem Stammsitz zu irgendeinem Internetprovider,
der das dann weiterreicht, sondern die sind selber im Prinzip schon Provider,
auch wenn sie im Wesentlichen ihren eigenen Content providen. Genau.
Und das ist auch sehr wichtig zu sagen.
In der Menge, wie sie das tun, ist das offensichtlich ökonomisch sinnvoll für
sie und sie haben ja offenbar auch eben zehn Jahre lang problemlos dafür bezahlt.
Dann kam der August 2020, also seit 10 Jahren bestand diese Praxis und dann
haben die verhandelt über die Verlängerung der Vereinbarung.
So, Meta hat gesagt, das muss billiger werden, wir wollen 40% weniger zahlen.
Die Deutsche Telekom hat gesagt, naja, 16% Nachlass können wir euch geben,
aber ey, Leute, das ist schon eine ordentliche Leitung, die hier kommt und so.
Dann kündigt im November Meta den Vertrag zum 1. März 2021.
Ja, also die hat eine Vereinbarung, jetzt wird die zum 1. März 2021 gekündigt.
Und Telekom lässt aber das, was über diese 24 Übergabepunkte kommt,
weiterlaufen und sagt, naja, zum Wohle der Verbraucher und der Gesellschaft im Allgemeinen.
Gesellschaft im Allgemeinen weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob die davon profitiert hat,
dass dieser Facebook-Mist kommt.
Man könnte sagen, Facebook ist Instagram und WhatsApp und ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass die Telekom natürlich auch nicht wollte,
dass ihre Kundinnen und Kunden sich darüber beklagen, dass irgendwie Instagram ruckelt oder so.
So, und jetzt sagt Meta im Februar, also kurz bevor diese Kündigung ist,
naja, die bisher endgeltlich genutzten privaten Interconnects würden wir jetzt
gerne weiter im Rahmen eines Settlement-Free-Peering in Anspruch nehmen.
Mit anderen Worten, das, wofür wir jetzt zehn Jahre lang gezahlt haben,
im Rahmen von Transit ins Deutsche Telekom setzt.
Wenn ihr das nicht 40% billiger macht, dann wollen wir es komplett kostenlos haben.
Wir machen jetzt Peering. Was haltet ihr davon?
Also Peering wäre dann sozusagen der Status, dass zwei gleichberechtigte Teilnehmer
der internationalen Netzwerkinfrastruktur einfach die Daten sich gegenseitig
zuschicken und gar nicht groß berechnen,
wie das halt eigentlich auch üblich ist zwischen großen Providern.
Genau, man könnte jetzt argumentieren, dass das wäre eigentlich üblich und dadurch
daran, dass die Telekom das hat weiterlaufen lassen,
merkt man ja auch, dass das offenbar im Interesse ihrer Kunden ist.
Das ist soweit die Telekom-Seite.
Meta sagt jetzt, voll die geile Idee, lass doch einfach Peering machen,
dann müssen wir gar nichts mehr bezahlen.
Und die Telekom antwortet, naja, ab dem 1.
März stellen wir alle IP-Transit-Dienste zu den gleichen vertraglich vereinbarten
Bedingungen wie bisher zur Verfügung und werden die entsprechend auch abrechnen,
wenn sie die Leistung weiter in Anspruch nehmen.
Das hätte ich ehrlich gesagt anstelle der Telekom auch gemacht.
So. Und sagt, also nutzt das gerne weiter, wir werden das dann in Rechnung stellen. Was macht Facebook?
Zahlt nicht und macht weiter. Dann muss natürlich,
ist ja klar, dass die Telekom dann klagen muss und dann geht es vor das Gericht,
aufgrund des Streitwertes eben nicht ans Amtsgericht, sondern Landgericht in
Köln und das sagt dann, naja, ihr hättet ja auch einfach nicht nutzen können.
Ihr hättet ja die Kündigung erklären können und dann müsst ihr auch aufhören, das zu nutzen.
Völlig okay, ihr habt gekündigt, die Telekom hat gesagt, wenn ihr es weiter
nutzt, dann zu den alten Bedingungen, ihr habt es weiter genutzt,
ihr habt ja auch Kabel, die ihr abziehen könnt.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wärt ihr gezwungen gewesen, das zu nutzen.
Mit anderen Worten, die Rechnung, die die Telekom jetzt hier einklagt,
die müsst ihr auch bezahlen, ist ja klar.
Und das Gericht sagt, Meta, ihr hättet ja auch gerne über den D-Kicks gehen
können, habt ihr nicht gemacht?
Oder von mir aus nehmt ihr euch ja auch einen anderen Kicks,
ist mir egal, aber ihr wart nicht in einer Abhängigkeit, das zu nutzen.
Die Telekom hat gesagt, was die Preise sind, wenn ihr es weiter nutzt,
ihr habt es gemacht, also müsst ihr die Rechnung auch zahlen.
So, und vor dem Hintergrund entfaltet sich natürlich die Debatte um Fair Share.
Also das, was hier von Breton vorangetrieben wird und was im Kontext Netzneutralität diskutiert wird.
Thomas Lohninger hat auch das Ganze kommentiert.
Nur die Telekom Deutschland und eine Handvoll anderer Telekom-Konzerne verhalten
sich hier schädlich, indem sie höhere Preise als sonst am Markt üblich verlangen.
Wer der Deutschen Telekom sein Weggeld bezahlt, ist bei ihren Kunden besser
erreichbar, wenn nicht bezahlt ist, nur sehr schlecht erreichbar.
Das ist nichts anderes als eine bezahlte Überholspur. Und da hat er natürlich,
technisch auch einen Punkt,
aber ich kann schon, also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, mir war nicht klar,
dass es da 24 Private Transit-Dinger gibt,
Also das Ausmaß war mir tatsächlich nicht bekannt, dass die irgendwie eine schnellere
Verbindung und sowas haben, dass die in direkte Verbindungen gehen und so war mir schon klar,
aber mir war jetzt auch nicht klar,
welches absolute Ausmaß das hat.
Obwohl du dir eigentlich mit einem Bleistift und einem Blatt Papier relativ
schnell zusammenrechnen kannst, dass es da um eine Riesenmenge an Daten gehen muss.
Gut, 24 in ganz Deutschland finde ich jetzt auch für so einen großen Konzern
jetzt nicht überraschend viel.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Ja, es ist wirklich ein zweischneidiges Schwert, weil auf der einen Seite hat
natürlich Meta, also erstmal ist das für sie ja auch ein Aufwand,
also sie müssen ja auch diese Leitungen haben und führen die irgendwo hin und
haben natürlich dann wiederum einen Vorteil, wenn sie das an große Provider lokal abwerfen können.
Einfach weil die Daten ja dann sozusagen schneller fließen und damit die Latenz
und so weiter und die User Experience steigt damit so und das macht ja dann
letztlich auch die Telekom Kunden glücklich.
Letzten Endes haben sie es ja auch zum Wohle der Verbraucher und der Gesellschaft
im Allgemeinen getan. Das könnte die Telekom eigentlich generell mal machen, oder?
Zum Wohle der Verbraucher und der Gesellschaft. Da würde mir noch so einiges
einfallen, was die Telekom in dem Bereich noch so untertiteln könnte. Ja.
Aber ja, von daher ist diese ganze Frage, wer zahlt eigentlich wen,
wofür, ist wirklich interessant,
weil da kann man jetzt nicht klar sagen, wer jetzt mehr Vorteil hat davon,
weil eigentlich beide davon profitieren und man würde fast meinen,
eigentlich wäre die Telekom gar nicht so schlecht aufgestellt,
wenn sie das sozusagen generell anbietet.
Das ist jetzt auch für sie ja nicht ohne Kosten, weil diese Punkte müssen ja
auch aufrechterhalten werden.
Also es ist schon so ein bisschen Win-Win, Lose-Lose auf beiden Seiten.
Ja, wenn du dich mit Leuten von der Telekom unterhältst, sagen die natürlich
auch so, du hast ja keine Vorstellung, wie viel Traffic von einigen sehr wenigen kommt.
Mhm.
Also konkret könnte ich es auch nicht benennen, aber es ist schon klar,
dass natürlich YouTube...
Ja, also die sagen mir jetzt zum Beispiel auch ganz offen, Logbuch-Netzpolitik
ist da nicht in den Top Ten.
Was? Ja, nicht in den Top Ten der Last im deutschen Telekom-Netz.
Das musst du dir mal vorstellen. Also was da teilweise...
Das kann einfach nur bedeuten, dass sie ihr Monitoring nicht im Griff haben.
So jetzt, also, und ich denke, man kann schon sagen,
dass die Internet-Realität mit Amazon als CDN-Provider, Facebook, Netflix,
Microsoft,
dass das Internet da draußen zu großen Teilen wirklich nur noch einige sehr, sehr große Player sind.
Und dann alle anderen.
Und dann gibt es noch ein bisschen alle anderen.
Und jetzt haben wir eine Position, dass wir unsere Sympathien sind bei den allen anderen.
Dann würde ich jetzt mal, also ja, doch, ich habe größere Sympathien zu allen
anderen als zu jetzt irgendwie Facebook oder so.
Und dann gibt es aber natürlich jetzt diese Netzbetreiber, die auch versuchen,
eine Infrastruktur in diesem Land zu betreiben und das profitabel tun müssen. So.
Kann man das wieder alles in Frage stellen? Muss das sein, dass sie Profit mit
dieser Infrastruktur machen oder sollte es vielleicht so sein,
dass die einfach in unseren Händen ist und so?
So oder so, diese Infrastruktur muss noch zu Ende gebaut werden in Deutschland. stand.
Die ist ja noch nicht fertig. Wir haben ja noch viele Stellen,
wo es, wo die Netzflecken noch nicht miteinander verbunden sind.
Insofern ist es schon vielleicht auch zumindest die Motivation eines Netzbetreibers
verständlich zu sagen, ey, ist nicht schlecht, auch wenn wir dafür Kohle kriegen
von denen, von denen dieser ganze Traffic kommt.
Ja, vor allem, an der Stelle spielt
sich das ja auch mal wirklich auch auf privatwirtschaftlicher Ebene aus.
Also der Battle mit wer hat mehr davon, der kann sich am Ende eigentlich nur
über Rechnungsflow herausstellen.
Weil klar, Meta hätte ja einfach sagen können, ach ihr wollt es nicht mehr nehmen,
ja dann schicken wir euch auch einfach nichts mehr, weil es ist uns zu teuer,
aber das haben sie ja auch nicht gemacht.
Ja und das ist natürlich ein Hebel, den wir jetzt natürlich haben.
Aber ich zum Beispiel mit meinem privaten Blog, wenn ich der Telekom sage,
hier pass auf, wenn ihr jetzt nicht mehr zahlt, dann wird das halt langsam sein.
Und in dem Fall ist es natürlich, dann würde die Deutsche Telekom mir sagen,
Linus, pass auf, für dich stellen wir hier kein eigenes Rack hin und wir legen
jetzt auch nicht nochmal eine fette Leitung zu deinem Server.
Entsprechend, du kannst gerne über den D-Kicks gehen.
Und dann würde ich sagen, dann lädt mein Blog langsamer und dann sagen die,
das muten wir unseren Kunden zu.
Das muten wir denen zu. Bei Facebook machen sie es aber nicht.
Bei Facebook sagen sie, ah scheiße, brauchen wir schon.
Also hier sind schon irgendwo Interessen am gegenseitigen Tisch und dann könnte
man mal gucken, wie groß, wie viele Milliarden macht denn Facebook und wie viele
Milliarden macht die Deutsche Telekom, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß es wirklich nicht, ich würde vermuten, Facebook macht irgendwo Faktor so und so viel mehr.
Und einen entsprechenden Fluss des Kapitals könnte man sich dann da auch vorstellen.
Das ist dann dieser Fair-Share-Gedanke.
Um mal den Hintergrund dieses Rechtsstreits zu erläutern.
Also ich hoffe, wir haben hier jetzt objektiv genug beide Seiten wiedergegeben
und ja, ich kann zumindest verstehen,
dass die Deutsche Telekom sich bemüht, da auch Geld von Facebook zu bekommen.
Und wenn sie es zehn Jahre lang bekommen haben, scheint der Gedanke ja auch
nicht so abwegig zu sein.
Das ist natürlich schon das Spannende, was hier der Fall ist.
Sicherlich kann nicht das Ergebnis sein, dass man sagt, Facebook soll jetzt
eben halt über den D-Kicks gehen und alle sollen nur pieren.
Also ich verstehe ja Thomas' Argumentation mit der Überholspur.
Ich hätte jetzt wirklich nur Bedenken, wenn das jetzt wirklich in so eine komplette
Aufweichung der Netzneutralität geht, dass du quasi auf Kundenebene entscheidest,
ob du irgendwie mit oder ohne schnell das Facebook haben willst.
Ja, das wäre, das ist wirklich der Punkt, wo man sagen kann,
so nee, das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall,
aber wenn das sozusagen nur ein Battle zwischen großen Konzernen ist,
wer da wem, wann, wo, wie viel bezahlt, dann ehrlich gesagt,
sollen die das doch unter sich aus machen.
Ja, oder, also ich könnte auch, ich hätte eine leichte Tendenz,
wo meine Sympathien liegen.
Tja, aber das kann sich dann bei anderen Unternehmen auch schon wieder leicht unterscheiden.
Genau, das ist der Fall, dass man gucken muss, wie lange Zöpfe hängen da jetzt auch wieder dran.
Also haben wir behandelt, werden wir sicherlich auch weiter behandeln.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Meta sich ein Landgerichtsurteil geben lässt,
aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, dass hier, und ich hoffe, das ist auch genug klar geworden,
dass hier im Zweifelsfall ein relativ einfacher BGB-Fall verhandelt wurde,
nämlich ihr habt einen Leistungsvertrag gehabt, du hast die Leistung gekündigt,
dann weiter in Anspruch genommen, dir wurde gesagt, zu welchen Bedingungen du das tun kannst.
Dann kam eine Rechnung, die wir sie jetzt wohl auch bezahlen müssen.
Ja, also das halte ich jetzt auch. Also bin mal gespannt, ob Meta nicht vielleicht auch einfach sagt,
naja, dann zahlen wir halt jetzt diese Rechnungen und dann hören wir halt auf,
diese Private Interconnects zu nutzen.
Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, ob die Telekom sich da nicht eventuell,
also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass dieser Kampf dann da stattfindet und demnächst halt irgendwie ein Anbau,
24 Quadratkilometer Anbau beim D-Kicks ins Haus steht oder so.
Ja, dann wird sich der wahre Preis dieser Daten dann erst herausstellen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt meinen Stromvertrag kündige und der aber nicht wirklich
abgeschaltet wird und ich trotzdem Strom beziehe, dann muss ich dafür ja auch zahlen.
Irrsauffahrzeuge, ja. Finde ich übrigens auch eine Frechheit.
Ich hab den auch schon in meinem Brief geschrieben, dass wir ja jetzt hier einfach,
settlement-free-peering machen können.
Ich schicke euch auch gerne meinen Balkon-Kraftwerk-Strom zurück.
Ich hab jetzt hier ein Atomkraftwerk. Lass uns doch einfach pieren.
Und da... Hör mir auf. Naja.
Eine Meldung, die wir nur am Rande kurz behandeln. Die CDU hatte einen Cyberangriff.
Ich weise als Sprecher des CCC jegliche Verantwortung von uns und weise auch
sämtliche Spekulationen darüber zurück,
dass es in irgendeinem Zusammenhang damit stünde, dass wir seit August 21 keine
Sicherheitslücken mehr an die CDU melden.
Und damit wären wir dann auch bei den Terminen, weil du das eh wieder nicht
hinkriegst mit der Melodie, würde ich sagen, machen wir es ohne,
aber ich finde es nicht gut, ich hätte gerne die Melodie.
Ja, aber die Leute, es ist immer so 50-50, manche finden es toll,
manche finden es furchtbar.
Naja, also LMP 500, 31.
August, Berlin, Vorverkauf ab 25.06.
Ungefähr 18 Uhr werdet ihr diese Tickets kaufen können. Es gibt auch erstmal
genug, das ist glaube ich jetzt nicht so eine, ah ne gibt es nicht.
Ich zeige, ob das genug ist, also ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen.
Ihr wollt diese Tickets früh haben, um uns die Planung zu ermöglichen und euch
und die T-Shirts wollt ihr auch haben, um uns die Planung zu ermöglichen und euch das Schild.
Ja, kauft mal bitte.
Genau.
Das muss ausverkauft werden, sonst sind wir pleite.
Also das wäre, ja, wäre schon ganz gut, wenn wir den.
Dann gibt es keine Sendung mehr.
Wäre schon ganz gut, ja. dann weisen uns die Datenspuren nochmal darauf hin,
die finden ja im September statt und die weisen auf ihren CFP hin ja,
da könnt ihr also Vorträge einreichen,
das Symposium in Dresden,
und ich denke gerade also erstens ist es ein cooles Event, das zu supporten,
schickt sich an insbesondere natürlich,
wenn es in Dresden ist,
so So, damit wären wir in meiner Wahrnehmung jetzt durch.
Meiner auch.
So, dann machen wir das nächste Sendung zeitnah. Die wird auch wieder ein bisschen länger.
Und freuen uns auf einen angenehmen Sommer.
Danken euch für das schöne Feedback zu den letzten Sendungen.
Es tut uns leid, dass wir das jetzt dieses Mal aus Zeitgründen nicht mit in
der Sendung platzieren konnten, werden wir aber bei der nächsten Sendung wieder machen.
Genau, so machen wir das. Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.